♪ ♪
>> Shannon: A REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSIONAL REPORTS OF THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
DELIBERATELY MISLED CONGRESS AND
THE PUBLIC IN ITS EFFORTS TO
FUNNEL BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
IRAN AS PART OF THE NUCLEAR
DEAL.
CORRESPONDENT RICH EDSON AS THE
SPECIFICS FROM THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
>> AFTER CITING THE 2015 NUCLEAR
AGREEMENT, IRAN HAD A
$6 BILLION PROBLEM.
NUCLEAR DEAL GIVE IRAN ACCESS TO
ITS INTERNATIONAL BANK ACCOUNTS.
ONE ACCOUNT IN OMAN HELD ABOUT
$6 BILLION IN LOCAL CURRENCY.
TO USE IT, THE IRANIANS NEEDED
TO CONVERT THAT MONEY FIRST U.S.
DOLLARS, THEN TWO EUROS.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WAS
READY TO HELP.
>> I THINK THEY DID SO BECAUSE
THEY WERE DESPERATE TO GET A
DEAL.
ON THE ONE HAND, THEY WERE
SAYING THAT THE IRANIANS WERE
NOT GOING TO GET ACCESS TO THE
AMERICAN FINANCIAL SYSTEM.
ON THE OTHER HAND, THEY ACTUALLY
GRANTED IRAN A SPECIFIC LICENSE
TO ALLOW THEM TO TAKE SOME OF
THE FUNDS THAT HAD BEEN IN
ESCROW.
>> A REPORT FROM THE REPUBLICAN
MAJORITY OF THE SENATE PERMANENT
SUBCOMMITTEE ON INVESTIGATIONS
AS THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
BYPASS EXISTING SANCTIONS AND
CLEARED THE WAY FOR IRAN TO USE
THE U.S. FINANCIAL SYSTEM.
EVEN AS OFFICIALS CLAIMED THAT
WOULD NEVER HAPPEN.
THE SENATE REPORT CITES PLEDGES,
THEN SECRETARY AND OTHER TOP
OFFICIALS.
>> IRAN WILL BE DENIED ACCESS TO
THE WORLD'S MOST IMPORTANT
MARKETS.
>> THE REPORT SAYS IN
JANUARY 2016 IRAN COMPLAINED
ABOUT ITS NEARLY $6 BILLION
STUCK IN AN OMAN BANK.
ONE MONTH LATER, THE OBAMA
TREASURY DEPARTMENT ISSUED A
LICENSE, ALLOWING A TRANSACTION
THAT FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WOULD
OTHERWISE PROHIBIT.
OFFICIALS TRIED TO PERSUADE TWO
U.S. BANKS TO EXECUTED.
THE REPORT SAYS "BOTH U.S. BANKS
EVENTUALLY DECLINED PRIMARILY
DUE TO THE UNWILLINGNESS TO TAKE
ON THE LEGAL AND COMPLIANCE RISK
BUT ALSO REPUTATIONAL CONCERNS
IN DOING BUSINESS WITH A
CONFERENCE HEAVILY SANCTIONED
COUNTRY LIKE IRAN."
FORMER ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL
REFUSED TO GO ON RECORD BUT
TELLS FOX NEWS THE LICENSE
FULFILLED U.S. COMMITMENTS UNDER
THE NUCLEAR AGREEMENT TO "GIVE
IRAN ACCESS TO POOLS OF ITS
MONEY HELD OVERSEAS.
THE SPECIFIC LICENSE CANNOT BE
DESCRIBED AS GRANTING ACCESS TO
THE U.S. FINANCIAL SYSTEM."
AS FOR WHAT HAPPENED TO THE
$6 BILLION IN OMAN, THE REPORT
SAYS IRAN LIKELY RETRIEVED IT